the economy for which as the mainstream
media have been telling me for months
and months Barack Obama is solely
responsible and Donald Trump is not in
any way responsible has tanked we will
analyze why stocks are down and most
importantly who to blame then it's our
100th episode to celebrate will be using
daily wires incredible streaming
technology to interview future me
Michael from the 200th episode boy that
is that is going to be great I can't
wait to see how incredible our show
looks by the 200th episode Marshall it
may gonna be great I can't can't wait
then Amanda presto Giacomo and Josh Asma
joined the panel of deplorable z' to
discuss Harvard's banning all single
gender clubs except for the female ones
equality hashtag equality we will also
discuss the English teacher who was
fired and reported to a counterterrorism
agency for telling a lesbian student
that God loves her and finally satanic
yoga then because all nature is but art
unknown to thee this day in history is
both Ronald Reagan's birthday and 73
years later the day that the Gipper
announced the Reagan doctrine we will
cover it all I am Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there is a lot to get to today
especially me interviewing me from the
200th episode that's gonna be pretty
wild I've never seen something like that
before
I wonder how much bigger our studio
guests would be nice to get out of this
broom closet we'll probably even be on
network television by then so we'll get
to that right away but not before we
talk about man crates man crates are you
know I talk about man crates all the
time I love them I have several man
crates products in my pocket right now
to light up my stogies and problem
probably a whiskey glass in there too
just from last night bumbling around man
crates is excellent so Valentine's Day
is coming up giving your guy a box of
chocolates for Valentine's Day is so so
boring you should surprise him with a
heart-shaped box of delicious beef jerky
the ultimate snack for Daisy ACK I can
tell you look I've tried everything I've
tried oystamato nothing puts me in the
right mood for the boudoir quite like a
heart-shaped box of beef jerky and a
Stanford easyacc that brings us to man
crates dot-com which is the only place
to find awesome gifts that men will love
this isn't a cologne thing or a cheesy
mug man crates offers curated gift
collections for every type of guy from
the sports fanatic to the home chef to
the outdoorsman I'm none of those guys
but I do like whiskey and cigars and hey
you have to separate actually multiple
man crates even just for those but they
have a lot of really good ones they have
the classics like the NFL bar where
crate the whiskey appreciation crate if
fresh takes on traditional Valentine's
gifts like the jerky heart or the salami
bouquet that's actually how sweet little
ELISA proposed to me she got down on one
knee offered me a salami bouquet I was
hers forever I go to man crates dot-com
pick the perfect gift then wait for that
magic moment he will fall head over
heels when this gift arrives and the way
it comes you might have seen this ad a
little trouble opening it you know
because I'm not the most beefcake Adonis
that's walking around and so the man
crate comes and I got my gift wrapped
which means they put it in a lot of duct
tape then they give you a crowbar and
you have to fit it up and pry open the
crate and then you get all of the cool
stuff that's inside it's it's a lot of
fun if you can't do it if you have some
trouble you go to the help page and it
says try harder which is good advice
good advice for everything in life
so you've got to check it that's really
fun I talk about this a lot giving a
gift is usually much less about the gift
than then the relationship I gave this
to you this is a thing we share oh yes
Johnny gave me this so and so right and
the experience of opening this gift it's
really really fun they have thousands of
five-star reviews every gift comes with
a complete satisfaction guarantee so
what can you do don't say I never did
anything for you go to man crates
dot-com / Knowles kayo wles as in Sam
for 5% off they do not offer this
discount anywhere else so get 5% off
right now at man crates dot-com /
Knowles
what is it Marshall / Knowles go get it
it's a lot of fun okay to celebrate our
100th episode we are lucky enough to be
joined by a no doubt illustrious guest
he was not easy to find but through our
state-of-the-art daily wire technology
we are going to speak with Michael from
the 200th episode do we have him let's
bring on future Michael Michael Michael
is that you
Michael Michael
yep Michael it's me it's me from the
hundredth episode I can't hear you that
well holy
how much golf FA did I smoke
[Laughter]
Michael Michael you're not dead Michael
Michael I am you from the hundredth
episode are you are you doing some kind
of shoot for the 200th episode let you
get to two but I guess I'm not the only
one puffin on fifth no you make it 200
episodes what do you mean I didn't make
it to 200 episodes are you Oh Michael oh
you stupid swarthy loud your stupid
sketches you got a podcast about
politics be wanted here by politics and
culture and history you are you stupid
sweaters stupid looks like the feet is
cutting out let's take the feeds cutting
on Marshall
all right um let's talk about the
economy man was that just this future me
have alopecia or something like that
it's very that's very scary stuff okay
the Dow fell by eleven hundred seventy
five points on Monday no I'm sorry I'm
sorry I said that wrong the Obama stock
market fell by 1,170 points on Monday we
just got to get we're just gonna get fax
back back to you
this this is not looking good for the
future in the Obama economy it's the
Obama economy right President Trump has
nothing to do with it that's what
Democrats have been yelling and telling
me for a year so Obama actually handed
over a wonderful economy to trump a an
administration that has done not very
much to contribute to this strong
economy the economy was in a ditch and
Barack Obama pulled it out the ditch
shined it up put us back on the road and
took us to another level
Donald Trump is riding the wave of the
success of President Obama he has done
nothing to contribute to the success of
the economy right
works for me but if unlike Democrats I'm
being honest the story is more
complicated the Dow fell 1175 points
yesterday the market sell-off began last
week it's sped up on Monday which
affected global markets
yesterday's drop was the single largest
day drop in the Dow history the S&P 500
had its worst day in seven years market
volatility has been accelerating in
recent months jumping by more than 100
percent
japan's Nikkei dropped four point seven
percent that was its largest single-day
drop since brexit markets in Hong Kong
Europe in the UK also tanked then this
morning the dow dropped another 500
points a four trillion dollars was wiped
away from global markets yesterday
Bitcoin is down to around 7,000 dollars
after hitting nearly 20,000 in December
I know it's shocking that a thing that's
completely fake and made-up has crashed
so more importantly whose fault is it
well I am more than happy to follow the
lead of Democrat hacks on TV and start
calling this the Obama economy but the
situation is much more complicated and
with any complex system like the US
economy or the global economy for that
matter the president has some influence
the press the previous president has
some influence and on many counts the
president has nothing to do with it so
of course President Trump has been
touting the record market highs since
he's been in office this is
understandable but ultimately it's not a
great strategy because if you take
credit when the market soars you're
going to have a more difficult time
explaining why it's not your fault when
the market tanks I spoke to some friends
of mine in the upper echelon of high
finance or as I am told to pronounce it
finance and then in high finance their
expert analysis of the market drop is
that nobody has any idea what's going on
that's the best thing you can give me
sounds about right you know because
financial analysts are like sports
analysts and political analysts they
have no idea what's happening and most
of their predictions are wrong and then
they just keep showing up to work and
people keep listening to them for some
reason so there is one theory that's
interesting there's one theory that
there are a bunch of short volatility
strategies that are driven by algorithms
so when prices prices fall abruptly that
actually triggers more selling so
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
and feeds on itself and it gets you
crazy drops like we saw yesterday so in
this sense we can't really blame Obama
or Trump Artemis Capital Management
explains it like a snake eating its own
tail
so in extreme heat a snake's metabolism
will spike out of control and in this
mania it will be unable to differentiate
between its tail and food so it starts
eating itself until it dies like this in
a market where both stocks and bonds are
overvalued a feedback loop of very very
low interest rates debt expansion asset
volatility and financial engineering
will cause volatility to reinforce
itself both lower and higher it's too
bad that we don't have one of those
precious metal companies right now
that's sponsoring the show yes we would
be selling precious metals like
gangbusters but sad missed opportunity
what can we do Donald Trump certainly
gets credit for certain aspects of the
economy he gets credit for consumer
confidence he gets credit for the
repatriation of corporate funds held
overseas for cutting the corporate tax
rate to make us competitive the free
gets credit for economic growth at
levels that of Barack Obama's own
economists said we're impossible Donald
Trump gets credit for those things even
the IMF the International Monetary Fund
admits as much a couple of weeks ago the
Wall Street Journal pulled 68 business
financial and academic economists as to
whether Trump gets credit for the strong
economy the majority of them agreed that
he does that said markets correct
themselves this happens analysts have
been predicting this for a long time
HSBC says the correction is long overdue
the SP was up 8% in January that doesn't
go on forever I'm sorry to say you
weren't gonna get 8% a month for the
next 11 months the Dow's fall on Friday
was an ominous 666 points growing that a
good sign
Wharton professor Jeremy Siegel actually
thinks the correction could be a good
thing even up to a 10 percent fall we
still won't have a bear market in 2018
he says and that would be good because
we need to get through more months about
what eight more months now of at least
the appearance of a strong economy or
else the perception will become the
reality of electing Democrats I promise
you that will not be good for the
economy so let's talk some news with the
path
that's on the markets I wanted to just
break that down a little bit because
we're gonna be hearing a lot of
ridiculous partisan nonsense from on
both sides of the aisle for for a little
bit and I at least want you to know I
want you to have some honest partisan
nonsense
I want you to know where your propaganda
comes from honestly so we have the
lovely Amanda presto Giacomo and the
decidedly less lovely Josh Yasmine thank
you both for being here
the first question Harvard University
has banned all gender exclusive clubs on
and off campus except for the female
ones but all of the other ones for
instance they have ban the male
organizations and they've banned the
men's clubs and the the group guys
groups they banned and the fellows
lodges all of those are banned it's just
the female ones that aren't the move
hits fraternities but really it's
directed toward Harvard's final clubs
this is kind of like the secret
societies at Yale and it's these
prestigious clubs I actually have some
experience of Harvard's final clubs I
was not allowed into one during my
junior year of college we were up in
Cambridge for the game and I drank a lot
of Four Loko when that was still legal a
lot of caffeine and malt liquor or
something and I repeatedly blew a
vuvuzela into some Harvard guys face and
then they wouldn't let me into their
club so this is karma guys this is what
you get for not letting me in as far as
I'm concerned
Amanda women are allowed to keep their
clubs but men are not the logic here is
that Harvard men have privileged true
but women enrolled at the oldest
university in the United States
Harvard women somehow it do not have
privilege this seems to tie in a little
bit with the narrative here that men are
predators who must be castrated and all
women are victims a poll shows 31% of
female Harvard students claim to have
been sexually assaulted on campus
whatever that means whatever sexual
assault ISM is means to say what is
going on here is Harvard Yard more
dangerous for women in downtown Fallujah
tell you but as we've seen time and
again a lot of those studies are super
broad and ambiguous like for instance if
you had sex than you regretted it the
next day that would count as you being
sexually assaulted or you know rape so
there's their endless people I know
George Will did a really good piece on
this just
bunking a lot of those surveys so no
that's not the case and by the way if
that's the case then then if regret
constitutes a sexual assault then josh
is forgot to be the most wanted man in
the entire country I'm sorry I finish
your point Amanda with any objectivity
and then also it's just funny to see
this that this is like the status of
feminism today is that it's like
cafeteria-style feminism so we know
we're exactly the same or you know
there's no difference for men and women
so you know we're gonna have all these
policies that there is no difference so
there can't be a man's only club a
woman's only club but at the same time
we want the women's clubs because we
want special treatment like it's like
really patronizing and weird how trying
to say we still get the good stuff like
we thought you know we're gonna lower
standards so I can fight in combat but
at the same time I better not be in the
draft so it doesn't make any sense you
kind of just like cafeteria-style pick
what you want and that doesn't make any
sense that's why you have to subscribe
to real feminism which is acknowledges
that men and women are different though
they can be equal under real feminism
which is anti feminism and we need it we
need a quality so that we can treat
people with special privileges so that
we can have more equality or something
Josh Barack Obama's Centers for Disease
Control spent a million dollars on a
study to reduce rigid masculinity now
I'm not suggesting you're an expert on
this but why does the left hate men and
masculinity I'm being very mean to Josh
today that's not good why does the left
hate men and masculinity well first of
all I really appreciated your beard in
that future segment I knew it was fake
because you don't have the capacity to
go down nice here we go so as far as
rigid masculinity toxic matte and toxic
masculinity I think we need to
acknowledge that the sexual assault is a
problem you know there isn't acknowledge
that I think we need to acknowledge yeah
I agree I well it's a problem I don't
think that downplaying it helps and I I
think that while these programs may be
misguided do you think 31% of women at
Harvard University have been raped on
campus does anyone actually believe that
no III can't speak to those stats but
Amanda do you think there any one
percent of women on Harvard's campus
know there's harm to playing that stuff
up as well I mean there's harm to just
because then we have you know memos from
the Obama administration directing
people that you don't really need
evidence right if someone comes forward
you don't say tell that person that
they've been accused all we have these
kangaroo courts on campus because we
overplay this this rape culture nonsense
that's backed up by nothing but these
ambiguous survey so it's actually it's a
danger we need to go with the actual
facts
we can't it's a danger to play this
stuff up when it's not really there
that's right and this actually isn't the
craziest example from campus even in
today's news cycle an English teacher
like the country not like the subject
though she is a subject because she's
English an English teacher has been
fired and reported to a counterterrorism
agency because she had the audacity to
answer her students questions about
Christianity she's now a radicalization
threat as she told a lesbian student
that God loves her that's what makes her
a terrorist Amanda how has God loves us
become hate speech I don't know I mean
they're in this in this report in this
write-up apparently there's an atheist
teacher who discusses his views openly
who said some pretty crazy things
apparently he showed the children I
don't know high school I think I don't
know how old like these high school
these kids are but he showed them a
picture of like a naked woman or
whatever he was suspended for three
months and now he's back to teaching and
like nothing they know that's just like
a slap on the wrist but if you have a
religious person so you see the extreme
bias here happen to say that they you
know hold certain views and then tell
somebody that God loves them which
apparently is harmful you know they're
out of there that you know that it's
just it's another clear bias that we've
seen here in the States over and over
and then of course it's really strong on
college campuses we've seen that with
Ben all the time right and Josh on this
point
this show the silliness and maybe the
ultimate futility of a hard separation
of church and state do jihad ease and
Christian teachers who say God loves you
pose an equal threat to the public so
you're talking about the story from the
UK correct yes
where she was you know she was at a
government-funded school and she talked
about her personal views she was asked
about Christianity she was and she well
she she is Christian
she is Christians so Christianity is her
personal view right I I come from the
camp maybe you know I hate to be a
contrarian again but I come from the
camp where I don't think that the
teachers should talk about her religious
views at a government fund at school
Christianity she can't talk about the
religion of the Western well she wasn't
teaching a segment on Christianity she
was asked what are your personal views
on homosexuality and she answered and I
don't know if that's appropriate at a
government-funded school so she'd she
said I'm sorry I'm sorry you've asked a
question about the Christian sexual
ethic and even though Christianity is
the animating force of the West even
though it's the it is the major world
religion I can't answer that question
because if I answer a question about
Christianity the coppers are gonna come
in and call me a terrorist that's how we
shall run government schools look this
straw man I agree I don't think that she
should have been reported to a
counter-terrorism organization you know
that's that's obviously absurd but at
the same time you know if you're
teaching math or you're teaching you
know geometry something else and someone
asked question about your personal
religious beliefs then I think there's a
time and a place for that and from what
I read it sounded like she went on a
tangent she was asked a question you
know this is one and she sent a very
hateful statement that God loves
lesbians that hateful bigoted statement
it's a good thing that we didn't have
that our scientists weren't selected
based on their religious views and our
teachers weren't excluded for being
Christian in the beginning of modernity
because then we wouldn't have had Isaac
Newton we wouldn't have had Kepler we
wouldn't have had bacon we wouldn't have
had Pascal we wouldn't we wouldn't have
discovered the Big Bang because George
elementra was a Catholic priest that's
probably pretty bad we wouldn't have
discovered the human genome on and on
and on it seems to me a totally false
separation between faith and reason
between light and truth between church
and state
obviously England is a Christian country
there is a Church of England the queen
of England is the head of the Church of
England and must we then pretend that
the Queen the head of England and the
head of the Church of England reigns
over a country that is totally separated
from the religion that animates it that
animates the its laws that animates its
traditions and its institutions this
seems like pie-in-the-sky
leftist utopianism am I wrong Josh I
think it's a little bit more complicated
than that I think that you know touting
the achievements of Western civilization
while accurate you know it is turning
the Christianity of the great scientists
of the West the profound Christianity
the Isaac Newton spent years
interpreting Scripture I think the
modern UK is a very different place than
the you know then the England of years
past you know and holding up a
ceremonial post like the Church of
England or the monarchy the Church of
England isn't a ceremonial post it's a
church but they have no political clout
it's not it's not the same you know the
Anglican Church has no political clout
it's meaningless I do think it also has
political clout because the Queen runs
it we have to move on to that is a that
is a good point though because it has in
many ways the UK and the Church of
England have become husks of their
former selves and Josh may be
celebrating but I'm a little upset about
it man
moving on to this final question our pal
Matt Walsh I think we've all seen this
article floating right he sent out a
tweet and became public enemy number one
voxcom started writing hit pieces about
him and I don't he's that one tweet
about how ridiculous yoga is and people
lose their minds
Matt Walsh says that yo
is pagan and that Christians should not
do it Amanda is right isn't he
Yoga is pagan it relates to Hinduism
relates to Buddhism and Jainism the
exercise is thoroughly spiritual some of
the mantras that people repeat during
yoga are things that say I am the
universal self or the unit whatever
right the whole point of yoga is that
you cannot separate the physical from
the spiritual why do Christians and even
atheists indulge the spiritual ritual
for their physical exercise shouldn't we
just all do Pilates or something instead
I pretty much agree with Matt Walsh on
everything I'm very extreme just like he
is open about it you know I know how
hardcore I am and when I initially saw
this could be wrote a full piece on it
and that the comments section on it is
lit you need something to do for Friday
night read that but I was like okay this
is a little extreme this is like a
stretch you know but then I read his
arguments and lo and behold I'm just as
Extreme as Matt Walsh
it's definitely rooted in paganism and
if you remember when I was in college I
was on the soccer team and they made us
take a yoga class and I remember like
being uncomfortable because it was so
spiritual there are like it's not like
it's totally like detach from this it's
not like you know like things that were
pagan in the past that have been
transformed into like Christian
practices it's not like that it still
has this very like it's still a pagan
ritual and it still practices that in a
lot of these like yoga studios or even
if you do it on your own I mean a lot of
the poses and the things you stay like
when you when you Ecco the yogi whatever
yeah as big and so if you I think his
question is how does this advance your
Christianity how does this bring you
closer to the kingdom of God and if you
can't even if it doesn't then why not
choose a different exercise that's right
and they do the world you're going to
hell and they do have these different
poses they have the downward dog and the
Sun Salutation and the worship ball and
some of them seem a little more demonic
than others Josh you are a decadent
pagan but at least you're an insightful
why do a
theists embrace this sort of thing is
the is the cultural fascination with
yoga a to play devil's advocate here
literally devil's advocate in this case
and disagree a bit with with Amanda
is it possible that the cultural
fascination with yoga is a good if
dangerous phenomenon in so much as it
shows that self professed atheists and
the spiritual but not religious crowd
are indeed themselves longing for the
spiritual world longing for the
metaphysical world longing for God I
don't think that it's that complicated I
think that Yoga is just a product of
cross-cultural communication and what
the yoga that's practiced in Los Angeles
Brooklyn Portland Seattle is not the
kind of yoga that's practice at Hindu
temples I mean let's let's be real these
are you know millennial you know
kombucha drinking and vegetarians go in
and it's just like it's it's part of
their kind of like secular ritual it's
it's stripped of all religious
significance it's not a religious
activity and frankly Matt Walsh's
argument is ridiculous like this is just
a fun little thing that no worshiping
Moloch is a fun little thing no it's
really fun to ya just kneel down before
Baphomet it's so fun and little I do
agree with you most of these people are
just doing this sort of silly thing on
their way between kombucha breaks but
nevertheless the point of yoga is that
the physical is spiritual and the
spiritual isn't fleshed and there is a
relation here and everybody's got to
serve somebody I think a lot of people
can pretend that they're totally
independent they're totally liberated
they're above themselves above it all
floating in this ethereal world and
don't it's okay if I do something with
my body or if I per take in certain
activities that has no spiritual
significance or metaphorical
significance or moral significance but
they're fooling themselves because these
cultural culture is insidious right
politics is downstream of culture and
what you culture and cult come from the
same root and there's a relationship
between what we do in our culture and
the sort of things that we think about
the world
the sort of things that we worship as a
society and that relationship should not
be downplayed too much but I listen guys
this has been a lovely panel it was even
nice having Josh even having you here it
was very very insightful for both of you
thank you for being here we have Josh
Yasmine and Amanda Presta Giacomo we
have got to get to this day in history
but first before we can do any of that
I've got to talk to you about Skillshare
so listen I clearly need to bone up on
some of my skills I don't know anything
about foreign policy so I've got to call
Joshy asthma I don't know much about
feminism and I certainly don't want to
so I'll call up a man depressed
DiGiacomo
but this time of culture this time in
industry you need a side hustle you need
to have a lot of skills this isn't the
old days where you would work at the
plant for 60 years and retire with a
nice pension so I know it's the it's a
new year it's a new year it's a new you
man
I think everybody has already ditched
most of their New Year's resolutions but
hey maybe you should take this one up so
you can actually learn something
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 18,000 classes in
design business technology and more you
can take classes and graphic design
social media marketing illustration
mobile photography anything I'm doing
one on time management because I need to
find more time to finish that class but
hopefully that will let fix itself once
I'm finished whether you are trying to
deepen your professional skill set start
a side hustle or just explore a new
passion skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving it is really a
great resource in the old days you used
to have to leave your couch and if you
wanted to learn some of you have to find
somebody to go to a classroom now you
don't have to do any of that this is the
21st century take advantage of it
you can join the millions of students
who are already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners this is a great offer and if
you don't take it you're a dummy and if
you're a dummy then you should start
looking at Skillshare so that you get
smarter you can get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents that is
practically free that is right
Skillshare is offering michael knowles
show listeners two months of unlimited
access to over 18,000 classes for just
99 cents
you can't complain that you don't know
how to do something or you know you
haven't learned something you are
getting virtually endless knowledge
virtually for free do it to sign up go
to Skillshare comm / michael mi CH AE l
again go to Skillshare comm / michael mi
CH AE l to start your two months now
that it what is it martial skill sure
calm / Michael okay I have got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube before
we get this day in history this is a
good this day in history this is a
providential this day in history because
it's Ronald Reagan's birthday and the
announcement of the Reagan doctrine from
my hundredth episode but if you are on
Facebook and YouTube
I'm sorry folks you got to go to daily
wire.com you we've enjoyed having you
you're probably not watching on youtube
because they keep punishing us but
that's a story for another day
so go to daily wired.com what do you get
you'll get me you get the end reclaim
ensure you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get the conversation which I'm going to
be in it's coming up folks and it's
around Valentine's Day so we can get a
little lovey-dovey just you and me ask
the love doctor all of your questions
and I will answer them for you and
probably give you a terrible advice so
you get all of that that's great
forget about it you get the leftist
tears tumblr look the Obama economy is
tanking I don't know if I've said this
enough the Obama economy for which
Barack Obama is this sole responsible
party and Donald Trump has nothing to do
with it it is tanking and you're gonna
need these leftist tears tumblr to store
it obviously you're not gonna have a lot
of money to buy it so get it now before
the the markets go completely to trash
so it is the leftist years time where
you can get your leftist ears hot or
cold always salty and delicious go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back
it's time for this day in history this
day in history because nature is but art
unknown today and chance direction which
thou canst not see on our hundredth
episode on this day in history in 1911
Ronald Reagan was born and on this very
same day in 1985 Ronald Reagan announced
his foreign policy program the Reagan
doctrine which has been badly
misunderstood by his political
descendants so Ronald Reagan was a born
born a good American boy he he grew up
and became a star of film and television
he I'm sorry I've lost my place he was
oh yes he was called a dunce by the left
and self-appointed elite conservatives
alike he entered the Oval Office in an
advanced age he was divorced and
remarried he fought cultural battles
from the White House he frequently added
provocative lines to his speeches that
drove his advisors crazy he effected tax
cuts and deregulation at home and
strength abroad and he restored
America's leadership in the world after
a disastrous Democrat administration
yeah that's where I was that's what I
that's what I couldn't find that sounds
kind of familiar doesn't it that must be
deja vu I don't know on this day in 1985
on his birthday Reagan articulated the
foreign policy strategy that would come
to be known as the Reagan doctrine he
explained quote freedom is not the sole
prerogative of a chosen few it is a
universal right of all God's children he
went on we must stand by our Democratic
allies and we must not break faith with
those who are risking their lives on
every continent from Afghanistan to
Nicaragua to defy soviet supported
aggression and secure rights which have
been ours from birth support for freedom
fighters is self-defense these lines
have regularly been ridiculed in the
wake of September 11th as we now fight
groups of radical Muslims who appear
similar to some of the freedom fighters
we once supported even though really at
that point isn't even true there's this
left-wing suggestion that we funded
Osama bin Laden in the 1980s that's
patently false
but Reagan's words are entirely true
unfortunately they're usually quoted out
of context the freedom fighters risked
their lives to defy soviet supported
aggression to defy communism our mortal
enemy
the Reagan doctrine does not exist in
the ether floating above reality above
time and space the Reagan doctrine
guided the country to its victory in the
Cold War we won the Cold War
Ronald Reagan won the Cold War and now
we're here and we can long for the days
of Ronald Reagan the Gipper was a great
man and the 1980s were a great time in
many ways it was more sophisticated and
it was more polite and was more
civilized but now we're in a different
time with different priorities and
different challenges and different
political leaders applying strategies
outside of their time and context can
prove disastrous as we've seen in
several interventions longing for the
good old days is the sign of a decadent
culture a healthy culture moves forward
Ronald Reagan didn't try to solve the
problems of Chester Arthur or Grover
Cleveland so - we should honor the
Reagan legacy by living in our own time
and space and applying his guiding
principles along with timeless
philosophy and enduring tradition - the
challenges we face today to quote two
great men that's the only way that we'll
ever make America great again that's our
show that's our hundred show thank you
for being here thanks for watching for
these hundred shows I appreciate it I
haven't been fired yet by Shapiro
that's really nice we'll see what
happens before the 200th episode really
it kind of worries me is it can I affect
the space-time continuum or anything I
Mel we'll see we'll see what happens
please download this and send it to your
friends and leave five star reviews and
that will hopefully keep me out of the
dumpster doing doing unsavory things
this is the Michael Nolt show
I am Michael Knowles please come back
tomorrow we'll do it all again
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy bore senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex Zangaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua of era the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018